You are about to learn about the popular
statistical application SPSS from IBM. This
course from university professor Burton Paulson
will show you how you can use SPSS to explore
your data for actionable insights. Welcome to SPSS
an introduction. I'm Martin Paulson. And in this
course, we're going to look at these statistical
program SPSS and some of its basic functionality,
and give you an idea of what it can do and
how well it might work in your own data work.
Now, SPSS, the name deserves a little bit
of explanation. Once upon a time, it stood
for a statistical package for the social sciences.
Now it's just SPSS. But that's its origin.
One important thing to know is how popular
SPSS is. Here's a chart right here that
comes from the excellent website are for
stats.com. And what it shows is the number
of scholarly articles published in 2015, using
various statistical packages and languages.
And we can see here is right at the top is SPSS
Statistics. SPSS is number one, by far in terms of
scholarly research. Also, you can look at jobs.
Here's another chart that is also from our for
stats Comm. And what this shows is analytics
and job listings on indeed.com. In 2015,
one major source of tech jobs, SBS is on the list,
but this time, you see, it's actually a lot lower,
it's number six. And so there is a difference
here, between academic publishing and employment
in analytics. Really what this tells you something
about the population or the audience for SPSS,
the primary audience of SPSS is academic
researchers, especially in the social sciences,
but in other fields like business. Now, there's
some reasons that SPSS is popular in these fields.
Number one, it's user friendly. It's kind
of point and click interface, which allows
you to assemble code really quickly. You can
save that code as what's called a syntax file.
And then you can reuse it, you can adapt it
and you can share it with others. Also, SPSS is
really well adapted for data from experiments,
where you're comparing means via t tests and
analysis of variance, several important options
like effect sizes and power analysis built in.
And so those are some of the reasons for SPSS is
popularity, especially within academic research.
In some who can say a few things. Number one,
SPSS, despite being developed about 40 years ago,
is still popular. It's got an easy to use
interface. And it's easy to save and reuse
the syntax, giving you a code basis
for the work that you do within SPSS.
The first thing we need to talk about in SPSS
and introduction is setting up and getting
ready to do the work. To do that, however, we
need to take a minute and talk about versions,
additions and modules, which all refer
to different kinds of things in SPSS.
The choice is really making me think of an
overwhelming a plethora of possibilities ahead
of you. And it's nice to break it down a little
bit. So the things we're going to talk about are
versions, those are the release updates, the
old version one version two additions, those
vary according to what's included in a particular
purchase. And modules are extra functions that you
can get to add on to the abilities of SPSS. We'll
start by talking about versions. version one came
out in 1968. And at that point, it was called
statistical package for the social sciences
SPSS version 24 came out in 2016. And now it's
called IBM SPSS Statistics act like SPSS doesn't
stand for anything. Now for this course, I'm using
version 22 on a Macintosh computer. Fortunately,
there haven't been any extraordinarily major
changes between 22 and 24. And everything
I'm going to show you in this course will work
just fine in almost any other version of SPSS.
Now, it is possible that you've heard of
something called p a s, w at some point, and SPSS
was briefly called predictive analytics software.
During a trademark dispute after SPSS got bought
by IBM, it only lasted for a year or so and it
got resolved. The important thing to know is that
no matter what version you're using, the files
generally are highly compatible between versions.
And so code that you created in version 16 is
probably readable in version 24. There are some
backwards compatibility issues for advanced
functions like automatic modeling and so on.
But most of it is consistent all the way through.
Now we also need to talk about editions of SPSS.
And there are a few major choices here.
There's the base edition, the standard edition,
the Professional Edition The premium edition.
And they differ by price. And they differ by
the functions that are included with each edition.
So for example, in base, you get basic statistics,
you get linear regression, you get clustering
and factor analysis. On the other hand
standard adds on to that logistic regression,
generalized linear models and survival analysis.
It also adds drag and drop interactive
tables. The Professional Edition adds to that
Data Prep, forecasting decision trees,
and imputation methods. And then finally,
the top of the line premium edition of
SPSS adds bootstrapping, complex sampling,
exact tests and structural equation modeling. And
so each one adds on a number of other functions.
Now, this is the product pricing as of
August of 2016. And you see, for instance,
that SPSS starts in the base at $1,170 per
year per person. So it's an annual license.
And it goes all the way up to nearly $8,000 per
user per year. And so it gets really expensive.
However, I want to say this, don't panic.
There are other ways aside from having to like,
you know, sell your house to get SPSS.
Number one, there is a free trial.
And you can download SPSS and you can try it
for 14 days. And during that time, the best way
to do this is see if you can make a business
case and get somebody else to buy it for you.
There is also academic pricing student pricing
for SPSS started $35 for six months. It's not
the super duper version, but it is absolutely
sufficient for doing the majority of academic
research. Now, we also need to talk about modules.
And these are the components that add extra
functionality to SPSS. And they're the things that
differentiate the different editions primarily.
modules of rephrase the available
modules include advanced statistics,
bootstrapping categories, and complex samples, can
joint custom tables, data preparation, decision
trees, direct marketing, exact tests, forecasting,
missing values, neural networks, and regression.
So that's 14 additional modules. And this sounds
like a lot, but if you can compare it to the
9000 packages that are available for our, there is
a difference there. The other major difference is
that these packages, they cost money, so you need
to work that into your budget. On the other hand,
there are also free plugins that make it
possible to use code in our Python, Java,
and the Microsoft dotnet framework within SPSS. So
there are abilities that you can add depending on
what you need. In some way we can say this. SPSS
has a long history as far as statistical software
goes, there are several variations and additional
rephrasing. There are several variations and
additions that you can make to it by adding extra
modules. On the other end, it can be very pricey,
so it's something to consider when you're
doing the cost benefit analysis of SPSS.
The next step in SPSS an introduction and
setting up is simply taking a look at SPSS
and seeing what the program's like. And the
easiest way to do that is to just open it up.
When you first open SPSS, you'll get this
introductory splash screen. That gives you
an opportunity to open up some files, recent files
and learn more about various things that you can
get from SPSS. If you want to, you can click on
this box, don't show this dialog in the future,
then you won't have to deal with it
again, you can also just press Cancel.
And that brings you to the data window in SPSS,
which has a lot in common with a spreadsheet.
It has these rows and columns, where you have
one row per case and one column per variable.
But there's a very important differences between
SPSS and a spreadsheet. To demonstrate this,
I want to open up a data
set that I've used recently.
And then when this opens up, you see that it does
resemble a spreadsheet, we have the variable names
across the top, we have row numbers down the
bottom and we have data in the middle. Now one
important difference between SPSS is data window
and a spreadsheet is this. You have a Data View,
but you also have something called a variable
view. And it's the same data set but if we click
on it, we see it in a different way. Each of the
variables has metadata associated with it. So for
instance age, it tells you the time type of the
variable. Now these are mostly numeric, there's
a string variable. But you can see there's a lot
of choices here, numeric common dot, and so on.
You also can specify the width of the variable,
the number of decimal places. And then an really
important thing that makes SPSS different from
most other programs is the use of labels. This
column right here shows variable labels. And the
idea is we have a short one word variable name
over here on the left. And if you use a very
old version of SPSS, they were limited to
eight characters. And you ended up with sometimes
with very cryptic names, you don't have quite the
same restrictions anymore. But what's common
is to give a short name to the variable.
And then to give it a label, that is more
descriptive. In addition, you can have value
labels. So let's come here to marital and we
click on this. And this is a way of telling SPSS
that in that column zero means unmarried and
one means and married. Obviously, you can
make them whenever you want. And when you come
back here, you have the option of seeing them.
So I'm going to come right up here. And
I'm going to click on this one, too, which
will show the value labels, and you see how
they've appeared. Now, I can have them go away.
There were the variables, if I just
hover over, then I see the longer name.
Going back to Variable View, you can also
specify values for missing values, you can
give the width of the column, the alignment, and
then you can specify the scale of the rephrase.
And then you can specify the level of measurement.
Now SPSS uses three values scale, which is
a interval or ratio level measured variable
ordinal, which is ranked data, and nominal,
which is categories, you also have the option of
specifying whether something is an input variable,
a target variable, or both. And there are certain
functions that use those. But most of the time,
that's not a big deal. And you see that in this
demonstration data set, those haven't been changed
at all. So the first window in SPSS is this
data window. But there's more to SPSS than that.
So for instance, let's make a very quick graph,
I'm just going to make a simple chart here. Come
and make a histogram of age. and hit OK. And so
you see, I have a graphical user interface with
drag and drop menus that allows me to assemble
my commands this way, I hit OK. And then what we
get is a another window that opens up, it's super
tiny up here. So I'm going to make it much bigger.
And this is the output window. So it's a separate
window, the data is in one window. And when you do
an analysis, you get a separate output window,
you can actually have multiple output windows.
And what this one does is it has the graphs or any
statistical analyses we do. It also has a table of
contents over here that you can collapse things
or you can expand them. And an important thing
is I've got it set. So it shows the code that
SPSS generates behind the scenes to create this
analysis. And the nice thing about that is you can
actually use that code and you can manipulate it
directly. This code is called syntax in SPSS. Now,
by default, SPSS opens up only a data window and
an output window. But you can get a syntax window
as well. In fact, let me do that I'm going to come
up to File, New, and syntax. And this is a very
blank window. But it's one that you can type in.
Or you can also use the drop down menus to put a
command in there. So I'm going to come back here
to the recent command. And I did it histogram.
And I could Press OK again, but now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to press a paste.
And what that's going to do is is going to get
the code for that chart. And it's going to put it
right here. In fact, this is the part that we use.
And if I select that, I can hit Run,
I can also do Command or Ctrl R,
it runs the selection, and you'll see we get the
output window again. And it's done the exact same
thing a second time. But this time it did it from
a window where I'm able to have the text. Now a
lot of people are uncomfortable with syntax, and
they like the drag and drop menus. But a really
important thing about this is it allows you to
save your analysis. So you can repeat it again,
without having to go through all the menus. You
can simply paste the syntax from the dialogues
into a syntax file, and then you can repeat it as
many times as you want. It's also really easy to
modify things when you do it that way. And syntax
files are just plain text files. They're saved
with a dot SPSS extension, but they read Just
like plain text files. Now, these are the most
important elements of the SPSS environment, the
data window with both the data and the Variable
View, the output windows and the syntax windows
that allow you to save the command. And this is
what gives SPSS both some of its flexibility and
its power. And as you become more comfortable,
moving back and forth between these various
windows, and seeing what you're able to do,
both with the drag and drops and by typing
text, you will discover there's a great amount
of flexibility and power in SPSS looking to allow
you to do the analyses you need to do and get the
insight you want from your data. We'll continue
our introduction and discussion of setting up
in SPSS by taking a look at the sample data
that comes as part of the SPSS application.
The really nice thing about that is it
allows you to get started now start working
with things and see how SPSS works. The hard
part, however, is that it's totally hidden.
And so you need to know where to
look in order to use the sample data.
Now, if you're on a Macintosh like I am, then
it's going to be in your Applications folder
under IBM SPSS Statistics 22 or whatever version
you're using, then samples and then in English,
then you'll have them. In Windows, it's a little
bit different. It's going to be C program files,
IBM SPSS Statistics 22, or whatever
version you have samples and then English.
So you have to navigate to that manually in
order to be able to find those. But when you do,
you'll see a bunch of files there. Now, there's
a few kinds in particular that are important.
There are the dot s, a V files. These are
data files in the proprietary SPSS format,
they can only be opened up in SPSS. Usually,
there are also dot SBS files. And these are SPSS
syntax files. There are text files with the
commands that can run a number of analyses and
graphs and other functions in SPSS. Now, we can
try it in SPSS, by having you on your computer
open up the window, and opening up a file called
demo dot save. But let me show you how it works.
When you navigate to the folder with the SPSS
Sample Files in it, again, it's several hidden
layers down. These are the files that you'll find
these are the dot shp data files. And these are
the dot SPSS syntax files. Now there are other
things in there, there's something called a CSA
plan. That's an analysis plan. There's an XML
file, and there's a few other things in there.
But the majority of what we want to deal with, in
fact, rephrase. But the only ones that we're going
to deal with are the dot shp files, and possibly
the dot SPSS files. Let's scroll down here until
we find demo dot Save. Now, please note, there's
a lot of other demo files around that. So you want
this one in particular demo dot shp because that's
the SPSS file. I'm going to double click on that.
And SPSS opens up the file. Now you can set SPSS,
so it has only one data file open at a time,
or you can have multiples, I'm going
to close this empty file right here.
But here is our demo file. And this allows us
to start working with a lot of the analyses and
see how they work. In fact, I'll be using this
file all the way through this entire course,
because it allows you to do a number of analyses
that require specific kinds of data. And this has
it all set up. So I'll show you a very quick one
I'm going to come up to analyze, and to explore.
And I will get level of education and put that in.
And so I have a long list of variables that I can
work with. These are all the same variables, just
hit OK. And that opens up my output window again,
opens up microscopically here in the top corner.
So I'm going to make it bigger. And now I'm able
to start working with my sample data. And that
allows me to get some hands on experience to see
how the functions work in SPSS and to try some
of the options and see how they affect things.
Our next step in SPSS and introduction is to look
at basic graphics because those are always a good
first step in analysis. And the easiest way to do
that in SPSS is with something called graph board
templates. Really, you can just think of these
as graphs made easy. The idea here is that if
you set the levels of measurement in SPSS,
then SPSS considered just graphs that would
be appropriate for those variables. Now in terms
of level of measurement, remember SPSS uses the
Number one is nominal for different
categories. Number two is ordinal for ranks,
and number three is scales, that's for
interval or ratio level measurements.
And then when you're in the graph board
templates, you have two basic choices,
you have basic graphs. And those are where
you choose the variables. First that you want
to graph. And then SPSS will show you suggested
graphs, you can see what you want to do with them.
There's also an option for detailed and this is
where you choose the graph style first, and then
you choose the variables that go into it. Now,
these aren't exclusive, you can bounce back and
forth between the two tabs, and it'll be easiest
to see how it works. If we just go to SPSS,
if you're logged into data lab.cc, then you
should be able to download the exercise files
from the same page that this video is on, open
up this file SPSS, oh one, underscore three
underscore one underscore graph board dot SPSS
syntax file. And let's see what it looks like.
Syntax file that you've opened, looks kind
of complicated. But this is really because
I want to have a written record of the same
things that we're going to do with the drag
and drop menus and the graph board, we do need
to open a data set. And as I mentioned before,
depending on whether you're on a Macintosh or on
a Windows computer, the path to the data set is
a little bit different. And also depending
on the version you're using, I'm using 22.
And so if you're using something else changed that
number right there, most of it should be the same.
And you can run this command and open up the
dataset and activate it. Now I've already done
that, I'll show you. There's my data set right
there as the demo dot save. And we can come
down here to Variable View. And see the levels of
measurement that SPSS is assigned to these. Most
of them are scale, we have a few that are ordinal,
we have only one variable in this data set that's
truly coded as nominal. And that's gender, which
is actually a string variable. In this case.
I'll go back to this index.
Now, I have some rather complicated syntax here.
But what you'll see is that when we use the menus,
it's actually pretty simple. The first thing
we're going to do is make a chart of age. But I'm
going to come up here to graphs to the graph board
template chooser. And when I come to that, you see
I'm in this tab of basic graphs, and this is where
I choose a variable. I'm going to choose age right
here. And it recommends three different kinds of
charts, a dot plot the histogram and the histogram
with a normal distribution. We'll take the very
first one that's available dot plot, and hit OK.
It puts it in the output window, which I have
to maximize. And there it is, it's a dot plot
looks a lot like a histogram of aging year. So it
goes down to 18 years, it looks like it goes up to
about 7778. And it's an easy way to get a feel of
the distribution that we're dealing with. Again,
the command in text and syntax is complicated.
But the graphical interface makes this very easy
to do. Go back to the syntax for a moment. If you
were to paste the syntax for that command, this
is what you would see right here. And this way of
saving it, you can modify it manually if you want.
Now we'll do a histogram of age with
a superimposed normal distribution.
Again, I'll come up to graphs, graph board
template chooser. And this time, all I
have to do is come over to the right, I click
histogram with normal distribution, and hit OK.
Expand the output window. And it's really simple.
Now both of those charts that I showed you
were with age, which is a ratio level or
scaled variable in SPSS terminology, we can also
do this with categorical variables, I'll use
gender and make a bar chart,
come back up to graphs,
hit GRAPH board template chooser. And when
I come down to gender, you'll see that the
Recommended Charts change because this
time it knows it's a categorical variable.
Now, if I had GPS data, I could put that in
here, I can do a bunch of different things,
I'm just gonna do a bar chart because that's
the easiest to deal with. I'll hit OK.
Make the output window bigger. There's
my bar chart and you see that in this
particular data set, we have an almost exactly
equal number of men and women or data on them.
Now, those are the basic charts where you choose
the variable first and SPSS recommends particular
graphs. You can also do detailed charts. These are
ones where you choose the style of chart first and
then you fill in the variable. I'm going to do
this again for $1 plot of income and then show
you that it's really easy to modify it, come
up to graphs to graph board template chooser.
This time, I'll go to the detailed tab, click
on that. And I'm going to make a dot plot.
So I'm going to scroll through this, you see
we have a lot of choices. Choose dot plot. And
that's going to ask what I want to make a dot
plot of. I'm going to click on this, and I'm
going to scroll to income. See, the one that I
want is right here, household income and 1000s.
I can click OK. then expand the output window.
And here's my chart. It's really basic charting,
you see that most of the people are at
the low end, especially because this
is hundreds of 1000s of dollars. So that's
going to be a million dollars right there.
But I want to show you an interesting thing
about this. If we double click on the chart,
that opens up the Edit window, and the
graph board editor has some special options.
For one thing, I can change the number of
decimal places here, I just click on the decimals
come to format and change the minimum level, or
rather the minimum number of decimals to zero.
That's better. But the more interesting one is,
if I click on the dots themselves, they're done
as points and the modifier is to pile them, there
are a few other modifiers that can be useful. One
is to dodge them. And what that does is it puts
them in the middle of expanding out either way,
it might be a little harder to make comparisons
from one level to another. But it's an interesting
kind of chart, I can click on it again. And
we can do what's called jitter with a normal
distribution, and that takes points with the same
value and it kind of randomly spreads them out,
up and down. And again, you can see that
we've got a whole lot there at the bottom.
One other choice is jitter uniform, which makes
them stay within certain boundaries. But it's
hard to tell really how much things are spread
out there at the bottom. So I actually prefer
pile or I think dodge is interesting in this case.
And so that's one way of using graph board to both
set it up and then to manually modify
it by double clicking on the chart
can close this because I'm done with that. And
you see I have the modified version right there.
Now, we can get a lot more complicated. So
for instance, I can make a scatterplot of
age and income with colors for point
density. There's a lot of options,
and you can explore them. This time, I'm going
to do a little bit differently, I'm just going to
select this command. And again, the way I got
these was by setting them up in the menus and then
simply hitting paste, and it put this index
into this index file, so I could save it and
run it later. So I'm going to show you how that
works. I've got the command here that I created
using the graph board template chooser. And
I'll simply come up and select Run selection.
And I maximize that window. And there you can see
I actually have what's called a hex scatterplot.
And it's showing a few different things. And
it's a really neat way. So you have a lot of
options on the way you display things in the
graph board template chooser. And while the
code is complicated, the interaction with the
menus is really simple. He can be creative and
you can get different views on your data and try
to get more insight as you're doing your analysis.
The next step in our introduction to SPSS
and basic graphics is bar charts. And we
like bar charts for a very simple reason. They are
simple and simple is good, or more specifically,
bar charts are the most basic graphic for the most
basic data just frequencies for a simple category.
It's also a very basic command in SPSS. Now,
we actually have a few options on different
kinds of bar charts. One, we can make a simple
bar chart, so a single variable simply showing
the category frequencies in that variable, too.
We can do a group bar chart where we break it
down by some other variable. And then three,
we can do multiple variables and show the bars
simultaneously. But let's try this in SPSS, it's
really easy to do, just open up this SPSS syntax
file, and we'll give it a whirl. Once you've
got the file open, you'll need to open the demo
data set and we've used it before. This is the
command for Mac if you're running 22 and this
is the command for Windows if you're running 22
just change the version number if you need to.
Once you have the file open, we're going to make
some bar graphs. Now I'm going to do it by coming
up here to what are called the legacy dialogues.
These are specialized ones One graph only
dialogues that come from earlier versions of SPSS.
And truthfully, I usually use these because I find
them so quick and easy to deal with, what we're
going to do is we're going to make a bar chart for
levels of education in our sample. So I'm gonna
hit bar, we're going to do a simple bar chart.
And we'll do groups of cases.
And all I need to do is hit level of education,
put it into the category axis, and hit OK.
And I make the output bigger. There it is,
absolute Piece of cake. And it's also very, very
simple syntax. You see this syntax right here,
it's really could be one line. And just
as a point of comparison, here's the same
chart produced with the chart builder. But
you see, we have this really complicated,
overwhelming code, the legacy chart produces
an extremely simple way. So that's a simple bar
chart, Piece of cake. Now let's do a clustered
bar chart for groups of cases, we'll look at
levels of education by gender. To do that, we
come back up to graphs, legacy dialogues to bar.
And now we're going to cluster it into a level
of education clustered by gender, I hit define,
get level of education, that sort of our
outcome variable, put that under category axis,
and then define clusters by gender,
I put that right there. I'll hit OK.
And make it bigger. And this time, it uses nicer
colors. But you have the five levels of education
broken down where women are in blue, and men
are in green. But it's really easy to see here,
the relationship between the two variables.
And in this particular data set, it really
looks like there's no substantial difference
between the men and women. Now, I will say
I believe this is an artificial data set.
So we wouldn't expect a lot of differences.
But this is a nice way to compare them. By the
way, come up, and you'll see that the code for
this is really simple. All it does is it adds
by gender. So again, a very short command,
I'm going to go back to the syntax. And we're
going to do one more here. And that is for
multiple variables. So this is a situation
in which it can be confusing if you have
a lot of categories within each variable. What
I'm doing here, is I'm going to get the means of
variables or the numbers of ones. If you have an
indicator variable where 04 No, no one, four, yes,
this is a really nice way of comparing
the frequencies of each one of them
across. I'll show you how that works. We'll
go up to graphs, we'll come back over to bar.
And we're going to do a simple one. But this
time we're doing separate variables define.
Then I'm gonna come down here and this data
set. Again, which I believe is fictional,
asked a lot of people about various things
that they might do. We're gonna ask them about
wireless service. And we're going to come down to
whether they own a fax machine, because this is
old data. And it's asking about old technology
pagers, I've never had a pager. But I simply
select all those variables, I put them in here.
And as long as they're all in the same scale, it's
going to do the mean of each one. And on the 01,
the mean is the proportion of one's head, okay.
And there we have it, it's a way
of looking at the distribution of
multiple variables simultaneously. It's a very
information dense display. And especially when
you're the analysts are exploring your data,
this can be a really quick and easy way
of getting a feel for your data, which
can then direct your further analyses.
As we continue to look at basic graphics in
SPSS, a really common one is histograms. And
this is a graphic for data that is quantitative
or scaled or measured, or interval or ratio level,
those really all are referring to basically
the same thing. And in any of them,
you're going to want to make a histogram to see
what the variable is like. Now, I mentioned that
SPSS prefers the terms scale for these variables.
And that's what shows up in the data definitions.
And I like to think of it as the scales of
justice. But why are we making a histogram? The
point is to see what you have to see what the data
is like. And there's a few things in particular
that you're going to be looking for. Number one,
you're going to be looking for the shape of the
distribution, is it uni modal, bi modal skewed,
left skewed right? Are there gaps in the data
This suggests that maybe you have some important
mechanism operating or they're out wires that
you would need to take consideration of before
you do your analysis. Is your data symmetrical,
there are a lot of different things that you
could look for. And some of these are going to
have a lot of influence on your analyses. So it's
important to take a look at the data and histogram
will give you a great impression of a quantitative
or scaled variable. We'll try it in SPSS, simply
open up this syntax file, and we'll see how it
works. When you're in SPSS, most of this is really
just to open up the data set is the same one we've
used in the others this demo data set. And here's
the code for Mac, adjust the version number if
you need to, and here's the code for Windows.
But once you have the data set open, you
can use the commands and it's really, really
simple. All you need to do is come up to graphs,
we'll go to legacy dialogues. And we'll come down
here to the bottom to histogram. And we're going
to make a basic histogram of age. So I click that,
and I come to age, it's our first variable. And
I simply click this to move it over and hit OK.
Make the output window bigger. And there's our
histogram. And from this, we can see that our
distribution is uni modal, we can see it's pretty
close to normal, it's slightly skewed on the high
end, but not very much. And this is going to be
a really good variable for most of our analyses,
because it means most of the assumptions of the
kinds of procedures that we might want to use.
Now if I want to make things
slightly more complicated,
because you see that the command
for this is extremely simple,
we can make a small modification I'll show you
here, we can superimpose a normal distribution.
And all I have to do for that is come back
to graphs, legacy dialogues into histogram.
And I just checked this box right here display
normal curve. And what that's going to do is
going to create the same distribution, we're
just going to put on top of it, a line of a
bell curve, a normal distribution that
has the same mean and standard deviation.
And here you can see, we're pretty close to
normal. And this is a nice way of confirming that.
And again, the code for it is really simple.
All it does is it adds the word normal in this
sentence, and that gives us everything
we need. One of the reasons I really
like the legacy dialogues in SPSS, is
because it's so concise, it's so simple,
and it gets you what you need. So you can
get a grip of your data and move ahead.
As we continue SPSS and introduction in basic
graphics, we should look at scatter plots a very
common method of looking at associations, or as I
like to think as a way of assessing togetherness
in data. In other words, you want to see
what goes with what or more specifically,
what variable goes with what other variable.
So scatterplot are a great way of visualizing
the association between two quantitative
variables. When you make a scatterplot,
there are some things you should look for. And in
case you're wondering what they are. They include,
for instance, whether the association between
the two variables is linear, because a lot of
the procedures that are common, assume that
you can draw a straight line through the data,
you want to check the spread of the data,
especially whether the spread changes as you
go from left to right, on a scatterplot. That's
called heterogeneity of variance and it can cause
problems with certain procedures. You want to look
for outliers, either univariate. That's a score
that's unusual on a single variable by itself. Or,
in this case, what's even more significant is by
variant where you have an unusual combination of
scores. And then finally, you want to try to get
some idea for the correlation or the strength
of the association between the two variables.
his counterpart will allow you to do all of
those. Now in SPSS, there are three general
kinds of scatter plots that you can do. Number
one, is a simple scatter. It's a binary x&y chart,
easy to do. Number two is a matrix scatterplot,
where you actually have several variables,
and they're simultaneously. And it's a good
way of looking at complex associations between
collections of variables. And number three, SPSS
is able to do a 3d scatterplot. But I'll have some
words to say about that a little bit later. But
let's try this and see how scatterplots work in
SPSS, at least very basically. So just open up
this syntax file, and we can see how it works.
When you open up the syntax file, we have the
same situation where you can load the data,
we'll use demo dot save. And you can use this
command if you're on a Mac using version 22.
And this command on Windows version 22. But
we're just going to make a couple of scatter
plots and it's a really basic, easy command.
The first thing we're going to do is make a
scatterplot of age and income, let's come up to
graphs, legacy dialogues, and down to scatter,
want to use a simple scatter, that's just a
basic bi variate xy chart, I'll hit define.
And all I need to do here is pick my
variables for the x axis across the bottom,
and the y axis of the side, we're going to
pick age for the x axis and put it right there.
And household income for the y axis. And the
idea is, maybe there's an association between
household income and how old the person is.
That's all I need to do, except click OK.
And when I get that, I get this basic scatterplot.
So I have agent years across the bottom,
I have household income and 1000s of this side.
And you can see, of course, that most of the
people are near the bottom. That's because most
people make less than $200,000 a year, this graph
goes up to 1.2 million. We have a marker that's
a large, empty circle, it's in black, and you can
change the markers. And there's things you can do
to clean up the chart. But it's also easy to tell
the people who for instance, make a lot of money
are generally older. So we can see in this data,
there is some kind of association between
age and income. But let's try to get a more
nuanced one by looking at several variables
simultaneously with a scatterplot matrix.
Come back up to graphs and legacy
dialogues. And down to scatter.
This time, however, I'm going to pick matrix
scatter, click define. And now all I need to do
is pick the variables I want to include, I don't
have to specify X or Y, because they're all going
to serve as both x and y in different parts
of the matrix. I'm going to pick a few here,
I'm going to get household income, I'll move
it over, I will get age and move that over.
Okay, address yours at current address and move
that over, I'll get reside, which is the number
of people residing in the house, move that.
And then finally, I'll get level of education.
There's nothing especially meaningful about these,
they're just ones that I thought would be easy to
look at. Now, as a general recommendation, if you
do have one variable that is an outcome variable,
you might want to put that one in first,
that puts it in the first column in the
first row. And it makes it easier to find
it when you're looking at your analyses.
But I've got my five variables in
there, and I just come in, press OK.
takes a moment. And then I come up. And this
is the scatter plot matrix. And so you have
all five variables listed on the side, you
have all five variables listed across the
bottom. So each one functions as both an X and
a Y, you have empty boxes down the diagonal,
because that would be each variable with
itself. And the correlation is always one. Now,
there are things you can do to clean this up, you
can change the marker from a big black circle to
something that's smaller and easier to see you
can put regression lines through. But it's easy
to see that there's some really important
patterns. So for instance, age in years,
and years at current address right here,
obviously, there's a limit, you can't live
someplace longer than you've been alive. That's
why we have nothing in the top left at that.
But you do see some associations and some cut
offs that go through. Now, this one's really
dense in a lot of situations, it's going to be
a lot easier to see the patterns that's there,
especially if you change the markers and put
in regression lines. But this gives a good idea
of what you can do with a scatter plot matrix.
Now, let's go back one more time to the legacy
dialogues and to scatter, because you saw that
there were other options there. There's a dot plot
that's like a histogram. And there's an overlay
scatter, which I don't want to deal with. And then
there's a 3d scatter. And you might look at that
you're like, oh, cool, it's interactive, it's 3d,
it's a great thing. I'm actually not even going to
do it. Because every time I've done a 3d diagram,
I found it, it's impossible to read it clearly.
It's very hard to manipulate in SPSS. And it
ends up being really a bad experience. And it's
much easier to look at the association between
variables using a scatterplot matrix. That's why
I recommend that you avoid the 3d completely,
even though it's available here. But avoid
it completely. And use the BI variate and
the scatterplot matrices as a way of looking at
the associations between variables in your data.
Once you've done the basic graphics for your data
and seeing what you're dealing with, it's a good
idea to move on to basic statistics. And in SPSS,
the most basic version of this is frequencies.
I like to think of it as putting things into
buckets, and then simply counting what's in the
buckets. So the idea is when you have a limited
number of categories in your data, then you should
just count how often each category occurs. It's
a first step to release some significant insight.
But wait, I just want to mention
that the frequencies command
in SPSS can do so much more than that. And I'm
going to show you how it works. For example,
it can do charts. It can do bar charts and pie
charts and histograms and normal distributions.
And they can do a lot of statistics beyond
frequencies, it can do quartiles, percentiles,
mean, median, mode, standard deviation,
variance, skewness, kurtosis, and so on. In fact,
because of this, I like to think of frequencies
as SPSS is version of the competent man character
in literature and movies, who can do everything
well. You know, somebody like Leonardo da Vinci,
or Iron Man who seems to be able to do everything,
or you know, Mary Curie right here, because she
won two Nobel prizes, and one of the rest of us
done. But anyhow, back to statistics. Let's take
a look at frequencies and let's try it in SPSS.
Just open up this syntax file, and we'll see the
things that it's able to do for you. As always,
we need to begin by opening a data set, we'll
use demo dot save. And you can use this command
in Mac or this command in Windows to do that.
Once you have the data set open, it's a
very simple thing to get the frequencies.
Now I have the syntax saved here. But really, it's
more as a record of what I've done, because I use
the drop down menus to create these commands.
So I'm going to come up to frequencies and
I'm going to get the frequencies for gender and
job satisfaction. To do that, I come to analyze
two descriptive statistics. And then
the first option there is frequencies.
And what I'm going to get is gender.
Just right here, I'll just double click to move
it over. Was it good job satisfaction, I'll double
click and move that over. Now, what's important
is these are two different kinds of variables.
Gender is a categorical variable, nominal. And
job satisfaction here is a scaled variable. And so
normally, you don't do the same kinds of things
for these. But frequencies is very flexible.
So I'm just going to hit OK, and we'll
see the default output for frequencies.
The first thing that it shows us is how many
valid observations are so how many of our 6400
cases have data on these variables? The answer
is all of them. There's no missing data here.
And then it comes down. And it gives us frequency
tables where it lists every value, or a possible
score on the variable, and then says how often
each one occurs. So for gender, we have 3179
female respondents, that's 49.7%. And the percent
and the valid present would be different if we had
missing data. But we don't, so we can ignore that.
And then the cumulative simply adds up to 100.
And then job satisfaction. This is a scaled
variable, which has 12345 as answers.
And here you can see how many people put each
of the answers 17% highly dissatisfied, 21.8,
neutral and 19.1 highly satisfied. And
that's a quick look at the frequencies
that we're dealing with. It's a nice way also
to check if your variables are coded well.
But what we can do is more than that, we can also
turn off the tables. And we can do bar charts
using the frequencies command. So I'm going
to keep those same two variables, gender and
job satisfaction. But this time, I'm just going
to make bar charts. I'll go back to my recent
commands and frequencies. And what I'm
going to do is I'm going to click this,
it's going to give me a little error message
because I haven't changed the other thing. First,
I'm going to come to charts right here.
I tell it to make bar charts, obviously,
you can make pie charts and histograms as
well. I'll click Continue. And then click OK.
And now the same general command
frequencies is not producing tables,
but it's producing charts. And here
you can see that we are very closely
mess in terms of the number of
male and female respondents.
And here you can see job satisfaction sort of
peaks at neutral and somewhat satisfied. So that's
a really nice thing. You don't even have to use
the bar chart command, you can do it right here.
You can also get more kinds of statistics
in there. So for instance, this one,
I'm going to keep the tables off when I'm going to
ask for a few extra things. In fact, let me just
come back to this one. We're going to analyze,
descriptives and frequencies. And this time,
I'm going to do age, reside and job set. So I'm
going to remove my one categorical variable here.
Just reset that I'll do age or
the other to resign. And job set.
And then I think that's this one right here.
Then we'll come down to job satisfaction.
And we'll move that over. So I have three
variables, but they're all scaled variables.
What I'm going to do here is first
I'm going to come to statistics.
And I have a really an impressive range of
things I can get, I can get the mean, I can
get the median, the mode, if you want the mode,
I think this is the only place to get it in SPSS,
I can get core tile values. Now it doesn't do
the minimum and the maximum, you have to select
those separately down here. But you can also get
cut points. Now, a cut point an interesting one.
The quartiles are cut point, it splits the data
into four equal sized groups with the same number
of people in each. Sometimes you want something
other than that. So for instance, I know that
if you're doing propensity scores, it's not
uncommon to use five equal groups quintiles.
And also, there are situations in which you
want not the most extreme scores, but near the
most. And so I'm going to put, for instance,
the 2.5 percentile. And the 97.5 percentile,
because those frame the middle 95% of the
data, I can also get the standard deviation
and the variance sentence or anything else I
want right here. I want skewness and kurtosis.
I'm gonna hit continue, then I'm going to
come back to this one, I'm going to turn
off the frequency tables, because otherwise, I
have a lot of different possible interest here,
I'd have a lot going on. I'll hit charts. And
this time, I'm going to ask for histograms. And
we'll put a normal curve on top of each
histogram. Click Continue. And click OK.
And so here's what we get. It starts with
the statistical output, here are the three
variables I selected, it gives us the mean,
the standard deviation, the variance, skewness,
and standard error of Skewness kurtosis.
We have the minimum and maximum scores. And
then the percentiles. Now it's a funny list here,
because I've got three things intermingled, I have
the core tiles, that's something I asked for. So
we have the 25th percentile, the 50th percentile,
and the 75th percentile. Those are the core tile
values. I had the minimum and maximum up here.
So those are the zero and 100% courthouse, but I
also asked for quintiles. And so that's puts it at
20 4060 and 80%. And then finally, I manually
entered the two and a half percentile,
and then 97 and a half percent. And so they're all
put there together, but it's really easy to see
the changes in the distribution. Beneath that
we have the histograms and we have each variable
has its own histogram, along with a normal
distribution with the same mean as standard
deviation laid on top age is pretty close to
normal. Here's the current address, however,
you can see is really skewed because most people
haven't lived there that long. And then finally,
job satisfaction is a little flatter than we would
expect if it were normally distributed. The point
of this is that I'm able to do a tremendous amount
of statistical and graphical work using a single
command the frequencies function in SPSS, one
of the most versatile commands you'll ever use.
In our previous movie, we looked at the power of
the frequencies command, but for basic statistics,
another very common choice is descriptives within
SPSS. The nice thing about descriptives is it
allows you to achieve maximum density. That is
how to get a lot of numbers on a lot of variables
in just a little space. That's what descriptives
is really good for. On the other hand, there is
a restriction, it works only with numerical
variables. But that's a lot of the data that
you might have. And if you have that, it can give
you things like the mean the sum, the standard
deviation, the standard error, the variance,
the minimum and maximum, the range, the skewness
and kurtosis. Now, I say that Guess what, you
know, in case you don't remember frequencies
does more, but that's okay. There's certain
things that the descriptives command does well,
here's what it does well, first, it gives
you a very concise compact tabular output.
So it's really easy to see a bunch
of information in a small space.
Second, it's a really quick way to find
obvious errors in coding in your data. Finally,
you can get proportions for indicator variables
as 01 variables and I'll show you how that works.
Also, we have a bonus feature here in
descriptives. descriptives is the home
of SPSS is top secret hidden one step Z score
procedure. I've seen people knock themselves
out trying to get z scores by getting standard
deviations in means you don't have to do any
of that you click one button and you're done.
But let's try it in SP SS and I'll show you how
it works. Just open up this syntax file, and
we'll see what you can do with descriptives.
We'll begin as always, by opening the dataset,
we'll be using demo dot save, here's the path on
a Macintosh, it running version 22. And the path
on a Windows also running version 22. This is
my first command, and it looks really long. But
that's because I have a lot of variables in it.
All we need to do is come up to analyze, to
descriptive statistics, and descriptives.
We click on that. Now one of the things it does
is it only shows you the variables that it can
analyze. So gender, which was a string variable,
meaning it had just text that's not in there.
But what I can do is I can just select all of
them and do a command or control a, and then
move everything over. And then I'm just going
to do the default analysis. I'll just hit OK.
And here's our output. We have
a whole bunch of variables,
and it tells us first, the number of
observations is 6400. Almost all the
way down this question about internet is missing
some data. But that appears to be the only one
we have the minimum value and the maximum value.
By the way, this is where I talk about quick and
easy data checking. If you have a variable that's
only supposed to go from one to five or zero to
one, if you have a 17, you know something's wrong.
And so by simply checking the outer boundaries,
that's a fast way seeing if there are any really
obvious errors, we also have the mean and the
standard deviation to the things, you generally
need the first two moments of a distribution.
And so that's a lot of information. And it's in
a very concise format. That's a wonderful thing.
If we go back to the syntax, I do want to mention
this one thing about indicator variables I said it
earlier, is this. If you have indicator variables
that a binary or dichotomous variable that has
only two possible values, and if that variable
is coded as zero and one, then you can in fact,
get the mean of it, and it tells you something
that tells you the proportion of observations
that have once. And this works best if you use the
standard programmer format, zero equals false or
no. And one equals true or Yes. And strangely,
in this particular data set, that's true for
most of the variables, but not the last one or
two and demo dot save. And I have no idea why they
switch that. But it's something that you want to
check in the coding before you go ahead and do it.
So if I go back to the output, you can see for
instance, that most of these wireless service down
through owns fax machine, those are all zero ones
were zeros, no. And one is yes. The mean right
here tells us that 99% of the people own TVs,
nine six own VCRs because this is a long time ago
that 25% had paging services. And I like
this one, where's the internet on this list?
27% of the internet because this was apparently
generated and like, you know, 1990 who knows what?
Anyhow, those are meaningful data points, the
mean tells you that proportion of ones or yeses.
I'll go back to the syntax here. And
then let's take a quick look at the Z
scores. Now any reasonable person would
think that Z score is a transformation of
the data and therefore it would be under the
transform menu. But you know it's not there.
Instead, it's hidden as an option and
descriptives. So let's go back to descriptives
unless you age in income,
so I'm going to reset this.
I'm going to pick age. And I'm going to pick
household income. And I'm going to get both of
these z scores because a lot of procedures work
a lot better if you have z scores. All you have
to do is this. Click Save standardized
values as variables. And if I hit OK.
What it's done here is it gives me the
descriptives because I actually still
ran the descriptives command for those
two variables. But more significantly,
let's take a look at the data set. When I come
to the data set, if I scroll to the end here,
I have two variables that
were not there previously z
age, pansy income, and they have lots of
decimal places because you need those z scores.
Now, I'm refreshed. Now under normal
circumstances, you would want to save this
into the data. I'm not going to do that because
this is one of SPSS built in default data sets.
But I do want to show you that we can do
one other thing here. Let's go back and
get descriptives for those z scores. So
I'm gonna come to analyze, descriptives.
I'm going to reset this Come down to see our two
new variables. I'll select do a little shift click
to get both of them and pop them over here, then
I'll hit OK. And as you would expect, a z score
has a mean of zero, and a standard deviation
of one. And we didn't have to do it manually,
we didn't have to remember any values, we didn't
have to round things off and did exactly for us.
And so that is what the descriptives command
does, it makes a very concise tabular output.
And it also allows you to save standardized
or z scores for use in certain procedures.
For a final look in SPSS at basic statistics,
we'll look at the Explorer command.
I like to think of this as a way to get a lot
closer get a little macro view on your subject,
get closer and see what's there in detail.
Now, the Explorer command is going to give
you a bunch of statistics, it can give you the
mean and the confidence interval for the mean.
And the trimmed mean, as well as the variance,
the standard deviation, the interquartile range,
the minimum and maximum, the range skewness.
kurtosis, is a collection of M estimators,
which are special robust ways for
measuring the center of a distribution.
percentiles, which we've seen before, and lists
of outliers can also give you a collection of
plots. It's the one place in SPSS that you can
get a stem and leaf plot. Now, traditionally,
those are things that are drawn by hand. So
it's kind of cute to see a computer do them.
You can also get box plots,
and you can get histograms.
And you can get a set of normality plots,
such as a QQ plot or a detrended QQ plot.
And the neat thing after that is you can break
all of these analyses down by groups. So let's
try it in SPSS and see how it works. Just open up
this index file. And we'll run through the various
procedures and explore and see how it can add
up to your own analysis. As always, we'll begin
by opening the demo dot save data set. Here's the
command for a Mac, here's the command for Windows.
Now, again, I'm saving this as syntax that
makes it repeatable, and it means that you
can download it and try running it on your own.
But I created all this by using the menu commands.
Let's start by doing a default explore analysis
for a couple of variables. I'll come up to
analyze, to descriptives, and then we'll come over
here to explore. And what we're going to do is age
and income category. And again, this is kind of
interesting, because these are different kinds
of variables. Age is a scalar variable.
And income category in this case is an
ordinal variable. I'm just going to leave
all the defaults as they are and hit OK.
And here's what we get from this.
First, we find out whether there
were any missing cases there weren't in this
situation. And then we get a collection of
descriptive statistics for these we have
first for age, then for income category,
we have the mean with the standard error, the
confidence intervals, the 5%, trimmed mean,
median, variance, standard deviation, minimum
maximum range, Interquartile, range, skewness,
and kurtosis, along with their standard errors. So
there's a lot of information there. And we scroll
down we find the same kinds of information
for income category in 1000s. Now remember,
some of this you wouldn't normally want to
use because income category in this case
is not a scaled variable. And a lot of these
things like minimum maximum and trim mean work
best with a scale variable. But SPSS is able to
kind of run it on everything. So interpret with
caution. Then we come down and look we have a
stem and leaf plot, where this is age, which
in our sample is two digit numbers. And so this
means 118. And each of these leaves, each of these
numbers over here is the leaf that represents
10. cases. Remember, we have 6400 cases,
we have about 640 numbers right here. And you
can see for instance, that the 30s appear really
common late 30s. And that we go up to somebody
in their late 70s. And so that's an easy way
to see what's going on. Simultaneously, we
get a boxplot. And the nice thing about this
as you can tell really quickly if there are no
outliers on age, not in this particular data set.
We do the same thing with income category.
And the stem and leaf plot looks funny,
but that's because there's only a few possible
values one or two or three or four. And
it's drawing it so it looks a little weird.
But we can come down and get the boxplot as
well and see there's no outliers, at
least on this kind of variable. Again,
not normally something you would do with a
rank order variable. But it's possible here.
Now the neat thing is there are additional
statistics. I'll do the same to statistics.
But I'm going to go check off a lot of options
that I have right here. So let's go back to that
dialog, I'll go to explore. What I'm going
to do is I'm going to say, just give me the
statistics right now. And I'll come up here,
and I'll make some selections. One thing,
although 95% confidence intervals
are by far the most common,
I have seen significant situations where
people use 80% confidence interval,
so you can change it if you want. Then I can get
all of the estimators. It's a whole collection,
I can get a list of outliers and a list of
percentile values. I hit Continue. And I click OK.
And now we have the same table we had before.
That's their descriptives up their top,
then we have the M estimators. And this is
for different robust measures of center.
Again, all of them are trying to give us something
equivalent to the mean. And you see in this case,
huber's estimator, turkeys by weight
handles, estimator, and Andrews wave,
the numbers are all pretty similar. I mean, it
goes from a low of 41, point 18 to high 41.5
to four, they're all really close. And each of
these has specific parameters that go into them,
you can't adjust them in the dialog box. But
let me just return to the syntax for one second.
You see here, these are the parameters for each of
the EM estimators, you could change them here, if
you want to do. I'll go back to the output. Then
we have percentiles 510 25, up to 95. And then
it gives us the case numbers for the highest and
lowest five cases on each variable. And so this is
a really nice way of seeing a multi dimensional
picture of our data. Now in terms of pictures,
and even better ways to do this with more graphs.
So let me go back to the syntax for a second.
And you see that we can get some additional plots,
I'm going to use age and income category again.
But I'm going to change that what it tells us.
So first off, I'm going to say give me just the
plots, we're not going to get any statistics,
I'm coming to the plots menu, I say well,
we have a stem leaf by default, let's get a
histogram. Let's also get normality plots. That's
a way of assessing how closely your data match a
normal distribution. I'll hit Continue. And Okay.
Now I have a histogram for age, the stem
and leaf plot. But this one here is normal.
But this one here is new. It's a normal qq
or quantile quantile plot of age in years.
And if it were normally distributed, all of
these circles would fall exactly on this line.
You see, it's really close, but it does deviate
at each end. And then a D trended one takes that
line sort of flattens it out, and it's much easier
to see where the changes are. Now I know it looks
really big in this case, but this variable is
in fact pretty close to normal distribution.
Then we have our boxplot. And then we do the
same thing for income, we start with a histogram,
our stem and leaf plot. And
our normal QQ plot, again,
a little weird, because there's only four possible
values in this data set. But they all fall pretty
well on the line. And there's our D trended plot.
And then finally, the bot file that we saw before.
Now there's one more thing we can do with the
Explore command. And that is we can take some
of these analyses and break them down by groups.
So if we go back to the syntax, we'll see I'm
going to do income and break it down by gender.
Let's go back to the menu here. But explore.
And I'm going to reset this. And we're
going to take income, and put that into
our dependent or outcome variable list or the
thing that we're pretending to predict. And
then we'll take gender scroll down a little bit,
there's gender and put into the factor list. Or
sometimes people call it independent variable.
So that's if it's an experimentally manipulated
variable for the predictor variable. I'm going
to come up here and I'm actually going to skip
the statistics and get plots only. I don't want
a stem and leaf but I will get a histogram on
get the normality plot. And now because I'm
breaking it down by groups, I can check the
spread versus level with Levine's test. The
idea here is that the data should be spread
out approximately the same amount for each of the
groups so we can compare them using some uniform
statistics. I'm going to do what's called a power
estimation here, click Continue. And then okay.
And now what we get is, again, is a list of the
number of cases that have complete data and then
all of them do that With no missing data,
we have a test of normality. And what we
see here is based on both of these, that
the data for neither group is normal.
That's okay, because we knew that
income was strongly positively skewed.
As for homogeneity of variance, whether the two
groups have about the same variance or spread,
you know, there is some difference, but they
are not statistically significant. And so it
appears to be the same for the men and the women,
which is good in this particular data set. And
then we can come down and see the histograms first
for women. And you see, it's got a really strong
skewness there. And the same thing, again, for men
really strongly skewed, then we get the normal qq
or quantile quantile plots. And again, if it
were normally distributed, all of these points
would fall right on this line is strongly skewed.
And so we have this really big bend in the data.
The same is true for men. And here's the
detrended lines, where they should all be
flat on that lines too, as you get this swoosh
Mark instead. So it just confirms that we're
not dealing with normally distributed data
they want you to have is this big collection
of outliers in the box plots, I'm going to do
one thing, I'm going to double click on this.
And then I'm going to come right up to here.
And this will turn off the data labels so we
can get rid of the ID numbers. And you can
see that we have a lot of outliers in both
demand and both the women and there's no really
obvious differences between the two groups.
And the spread versus level plot is something
that you can use if you have multiple levels,
that it can help you select a
kind of power transformation,
a square root or reciprocal, a square, something
like that. But that's a more complicated topic
and something for another day. And besides,
it appears that we have relatively homogeneous
variance in the two groups. So we'd be good to go
ahead and do our other analyses. So those are some
of the options and explore. And that's where
we'll end our discussion of basic statistics,
we can see how they can be used to see how well
your data meet the assumptions of the procedures
that you use, and then really, how well you can
make inferences from your sample to other groups.
When you're working in SPSS,
and you're accessing data,
one of the most important things you can do is
to create labels and definitions for your data.
I like to think of this as the statistical
version of Alice in Wonderland and the caterpillar
asking her to explain herself, you need to explain
yourself or more specifically, when it comes to
your data, you need to tell SPSS, what do your
data mean. Now, that is the data description,
and I see two kinds of information that you
tell SPSS about your data. The first one I'm
going to call semiotics, which comes from the
study of meaning. This is where you tell SPSS,
what the variable names are the data types,
the variable labels, the value labels,
the missing values, the level of measurement, and
the role that each variable plays. contracted with
that there are other elements that even call
aesthetics. And that addresses variable width,
decimal places, column width, and alignment. And
these are all settings within the data window of
SPSS. One of the most important though, at
least for human consumption is going to be
the variable and value labels. And so I'm going
to take a little time and talk about those
with the variable names. That's what the short
names the ones that you have there at the top
of the column, there are some important
rules. So the rules for variable names.
Number one, the names must be unique. No two
variables can have the same name, that shouldn't
be too surprising. It's an identifier. Rule
number two, the names must start with a letter.
I put an asterisk there because you can
start with an ad a pound sign or $1 sign,
but you don't want to because those are generally
reserved for special functions within SPSS.
Rule number three names can use letters, upper or
lowercase, they can use numbers, and they can use
period underscore at pound dollar sign, on the
other hand, don't end with a period that can
cause confusion with the command Terminator. And
don't end with an underscore because that's used
for automatic variable names when SPSS is doing
computations. Rule number four names cannot
include spaces. And rule number five names must be
less than 64 bytes. And most text coding systems
that 64 characters, but if you're using a
Unicode system that might be only 32 characters.
And the last rule rule number six is the names
cannot be any of these words all and by eq GGTL,
e, lt and E not or two or with Because those
are all reserved function names within SPSS,
so don't create that confusion. So those are the
short names that go at the top of a variable.
On the other hand, the label that you associate
with that you can give it a more descriptive name.
Those are the variable labels. And so there
are a few rules for those. Rule number one,
they must be less than 256 bytes. That actually
means it could be really long, although you don't
usually want to do that, because some procedures
will display as few as 40 bytes 40 characters,
and you really want to be able to read what it
is. So you want to keep it short. But you can go
longer if you need to. Rule number two, the labels
must be enclosed in quotes, although on tell you
they need to be straight quotes, the vertical
ones, and not the curly quotes are SPSS chokes
on those. Rule number three labels can include any
character, including spaces, which is something
that you can't have the variable name, but you can
put it here. So that allows you to put labels that
sort of float on top of the variable names.
And those can show up in the variable lists,
they can show up in the charts in the output
that you create. Another really important one is
value labels. So you may have a variable called
gender and you may put zeros and ones. But do you
remember what those zeros and ones are. And so I'm
going to show you some ways of dealing with that.
The most important thing is to put value labels
on there. So here are the rules for value labels.
Rule number one, they must be less than 121 bytes.
So that actually is really long, you generally
want to keep your labels pretty short. Rule number
two, like the variable labels, the value labels
must be enclosed in quotes, and they need to
be the straight quotes and not curly quotes.
Rule number three labels can include any
character including spaces, that's good.
This is an interesting one. And rule number four,
the value labels do not need to be unique, that
is more than one value can have the same label.
So you might have the numbers one through nine.
And it could be that 789 all say the same thing.
But they underneath have different code interest
situations where you might want to do that. But
mostly, I want to show you how this works in SPSS.
So just open up this syntax file. And this one's
going to be a little different, cuz we're actually
not going to use a data file, I'll refer to one
but I mostly just want to show you the syntax.
This index file shows how to write variable labels
and value labels. Now, you don't necessarily have
to put them all broken down in lines, I do
it because it makes them a lot more readable,
it's a lot easier to see what's going on. The
first thing is the command variable labels.
Because it's an SPSS command, it's written on all
capitals. And then what you do is you write the
short name of the variable. And then you have at
least one space and then you have straight quotes,
and then the long label. So here, for instance,
I've got vair 01, that would be the first
variable. And then this is its label written out.
And you don't need to have anything after don't
need any commas or question marks or semi colons
or anything. You just go to the next one. Now I
put it into another line, because that makes it
easy to follow. And I run them all through here,
I'm going to make one important recommendation. If
you have a dichotomous variable or binary one that
has only two possible values, and gender might
fit into that category. Let me recommend this,
that you coded as zeros and ones. A lot of people
use ones and twos, but that gets confusing if you
coded as zeros and ones, and named the variable
after whatever the one is. Now, when it comes to
male and female, I generally give one to whichever
group I think's going to have the higher score on
my main outcome variable, so it'll switch around.
But if for some reason, I think that men are going
to have a higher score on an outcome variable,
then I will call it male and then the label will
be are for respondent is male. On the other hand,
if I think women are going to have a higher score,
then I will call the variable female and the label
will be RS female, I would obviously only use one
of those two. Now here are some other examples.
I tend to give generic names such as variable
or really just q for question q one q two, and I
use the leading zeros so they store it properly
in the dialog boxes. And when you're done listing
all of your variable names and the variable labels
and quotes, just end with a period doesn't have
to be have a space before it that's leftover from
earlier versions of SPSS. It's a habit I have. So
you can run this at any time and it will assign
these labels to the variables and then they'll
show up in the data file which is nice.
Next are the value labels. And what you have
here is the first command Which is written
in all caps. And then you give a list
of variables to which the values apply.
And you can list them out separately, very
one very two. Here, I've got a VAR three
without a leading zero. And then if they're
all next to each other, if they are adjacent,
they can actually specify ranges vair, three, two,
and capitals, very tan, so that'll do 345678 910.
And then you just go to the next line,
and you give the first value that is zero,
and then I give zero equals No, and one equals
Yes, when you're done giving the values need to
put a slash, so it knows you're done
with the values for that variable,
then you can go on to the next variable. I said,
for instance, if I gave one on a gender variable
to men, I would call it male. And so zero, which
would mean No, they're not male, would be female
in one, yes, they are or true, that would be male,
and do a slash. On the other hand, if you coded it
the other way, and then you just call it female
and zero, which means no or false means they're
not female, they're male, one means they are fine.
Obviously, use just one of these, I do the slash.
And then I could have a rating variable, say, for
instance, a lot of people call it a Likert scales,
just a rating scale. And I could do rate 01, to
rate 10. And I can specify every value. So this
is a five point scale from strongly disagree
to strongly agree, finished with a slash,
or maybe you have a different kind of scale. Here
at the end, I have scale 01 through scale 02.
That's an 11 point scale, but I only mark the two
ends, the zero and the 10. So zero is never or not
at all 10 is always completely. And then to let
SPSS know that I'm done specifying value labels,
and with a period. So this is actually a
single sentence. And it's a way of telling it,
how you want the numbers to appear, both in the
data window, and in any output that you get.
Finally, I'll mention something about
missing values, because it can also be
easier to specify these in syntax, the command
is missing values. And you just give the names
of the variables and you can use two in the same
way. And then in parentheses, you put the number
that is assigned to missing values. 99 is
common. So I've got that there. And then you
can do a slash if you're going to use different
codes after that, I could do male through female.
And here I say two through high. And really what
that means is anything other than a zero or a one
is missing. So if I accidentally type in a seven,
you know it's missing. And then here I specify
several different values, I can put seven comma
eight, comma, nine. So if any of those show up,
those would be considered missing values, do
what you want. The nice thing is it will exclude
them automatically from analyses. But it will
include them in frequencies when you're getting
that output finished with a period. And then you
just run these like you do any other command.
And it's going to do a lot to clarify your data
and make it easier to follow your analyses and
reconstitute your work in the future. When you're
working in SPSS, and you're trying to access data,
you may get the idea of entering data. Well,
let me tell you my thoughts. You want to enter
data in SPSS, I just see it as an exercise in
frustration. It's a pain to do it manually. And
I'd say maybe you're entering 10 or 12 numbers,
you know, basically, nothing is something that's
often referred to as a toy data set. Maybe you
could do that. Now, it's also possible to copy
and paste data, but I'm gonna say sort of because
it doesn't work really well, I'll show you that.
It's much, much easier to just import
the data from a CSV file or txt file. And
I'll show you how to do that in the next
section. But in terms of entering data,
let me show you how it works in SPSS, we'll
just open up a blank document. And we'll try
it. So here's a blank data window in SPSS, I
can come right here and I can enter a number.
And, you know, unfortunate if I press tab, it
actually goes down, which is an unusual behavior.
And you see it gives it an automatic variable
name very 00001. Well, if I want to move sideways,
I actually need to move the right arrow key.
So I'll go this way to three, and so on.
And then I can hit return, and it goes down. I'll
come back to here and I'll go 456 I'll hit tab and
it comes back to the beginning. So it's not the
most intuitive behavior plus you see it gives
it these generic names. That's because you can't
enter the variable name directly in this window.
Instead, what you have to
do is go to Variable View
How to get there by just double
clicking on the variable name.
Here we go. And you can enter the variable name
and you can change other things you want to do.
It works, but it's a pain. I'm going to come
back here to Data View. Now, I mentioned you
can important data sort of. So let me show you
how this works. I'm actually going to go to
a Google Sheet that has nothing in it at the
moment. And here, I'm going to enter a few values,
I have a few different kinds, I'll do
5643. And I'll enter a number j, return.
Okay, so there's some data, I've
got two digit numbers, and I have
letters, which will be string variables
in SPSS, I'm going to copy those.
And we'll see how well they paste over
in SPSS. So I'm going to go back there.
I'll come over here to the side. And I will paste
those in. And you see that the values came in and
showed up with decimal places, and I can get rid
of that. But it's really weird with the string
variable with the letters and so you can copy
it. Notice also, I can't copy in variable names,
I still have to enter those in manually, you can
deal with those when you import. But really, this
is a demonstration that putting stuff manually in
SPSS, it's not a good environment for that. Use a
spreadsheet, use Google Sheet, use numbers, use
Excel, anything, enter it there and then import
it. I'll show you that in the next section. And
you'll see that it's a much, much easier process.
The last thing I want to say in SPSS about
accessing data is about importing data. And
you know, compared to entering it manually, it
just makes me feel like this and I resorted to
cheesy clipart to show how happy I am. Because
no doubt about it. Importing is absolutely the
best way to go if you want to get data into SPSS.
Now the nice thing is SPSS can open text files,
it can open CSV or comma separated value files,
and even XLS. x that's Excel files, as long as
they're formatted right. Now, what do I mean
by formatted right? There's a term from Hadley
Wickham in the our developer community tidy data
and it's referring to something very specific.
It says that your file should have only one sheet.
So that's one worksheet even though Excel can take
more than that, that each column should be exactly
equal to one variable. And that each row should be
equal to one case. And an important thing is no
funny stuff in your Excel sheet. Because Excel
is very flexible. And when I refer to funny stuff,
I'm talking about things like macros, and formulas
and graphs and formatting and comments or merge
cells, or headers, taking up their own rows or
duplicating row numbers. You don't want any of
that, basically, you want to treat it like a CSV
file. And if you do that, then you find you can
import it very easily into SPSS. And in fact,
let me show you how this works. We're going
to try this in SPSS, but I want you to do two
things. First, I want you to download the course
files. And that will include a zipped folder by
this name that ends with data sets, that's going
to have three files inside it. I'll show you those
in just a second. And then you can also open
up this syntax file that will work with them.
But let's go to see what's inside the folder and
explain a little bit what's going to happen here.
The folder that I've asked you to download
contains three different files. Now, I have both
the folder here, and I have the three files saved
separately next to it, but normally they would be
inside it. But for the syntax to work properly,
you want them sitting separately on the desktop.
All three of them contain the same data. It says
MBB, which stands for Mozart, Beethoven and Bach,
because this is Google Trends data about the
popularity of search for each of these three
composers names since 2004. This first one
is in CSV or comma separated value format.
The second one is a plain text file, and
it's tab separated. And the third one
is an XLS. x file. So it's an Excel sheet. And
you can see it's the same number but it appears
a little bit differently when I do the quick view
here on my Macintosh. What we're going to do then
is open up the syntax file. And we're going to see
what we need to do to import each of these. Now.
I've saved this syntax, but the fact is, it's
easier to do this stuff through the menus. Now
I give some information here about using the
file path. In each of these syntax commands,
I have to specify the file location. Now, this is
the format. If you're on a Macintosh like I am,
of course, you'll want to change Bart to be
the name of your home directory. If you're
on a Windows computer, you're going to need to
change it to something a little more like this,
or possibly depending on the version of your
operating system using backslashes instead.
Anyhow, I'm going to show you how to import each
of these. And I've got the duplicate information
here in the script, in case you want to run it
that way. But it's actually really easy to do it
from the menus. So here's what I'm going to
do, I'm going to come up to my data window,
I'll just click over to that. And my data window
is empty right now. I'm going to go to File,
Open, and data, you do that if you're opening
an existing SPSS file, or if you're importing
something in a different format. Now here, I'm
on the desktop, you can see my folder there. But
you can't see the three data files I have next
to it, because right now, it's only going to
display files that are in the dot save. That's the
SPSS proprietary data format. I'm going to click
on that, and come way down here. And we'll start
with the text file the txt version. I'm going to
hit that and now you can see that it's there.
I'll select that file, and I'll click Open.
So now I have the SPSS text import wizard. And we
can scroll through most of this pretty quickly. It
asks if it matches a predefined format, something
that would have saved somewhere else it doesn't.
It asked if they're delimited Yes, or delimited by
tabs in this case, are the variables included at
the top of the file, you see how they show up here
as the first row. I click Yes. And now it excludes
those because it knows that those need to be the
in the header of the data file. hit Continue. Each
line represents a case, I want all of the cases
you could sample from if you had a very large
data set, they would allow you to do exploratory
analyses more quickly than you could otherwise.
And that's what delimiters
appear. Now, by default, a
text file, the one that I have uses tabs and
it knows that it asks about text qualifiers,
I don't have text qualifiers in here. So I just
hit continue, don't have to change anything.
Now I have dates here at the beginning, and they
are year dash month. Now, SPSS can handle dates,
however, it doesn't like the fact that I'm using
year and month without the day associated with it.
Consequently, I'm gonna leave it just
as a string variable as a text variable.
And it still works properly in any analyses
I want to do. So that's fine. I'm just gonna
hit continue, I'm not changing anything here.
It asked if I like to save the file format for
future use. That's the thing I was referring to
in the first dialog here. And that's if I want
to paste the syntax, I could do that. But I've
already got it pasted, I'm just gonna hit Done.
And there it is, it's opened it up, and it's
formatted properly. If we go to Variable View,
you can see it's got a string variable, it's
got three numeric variables, it has the proper
number of digits, it has the proper number of no
decimal places, and it recognizes them as nominal,
which actually is not the case. So I actually need
to come here and change that to a scale variable.
Because the data that you get from Google Trends
is sort of zero to one percentages in terms of
relative popularity, search terms, change
that to scale. And otherwise, I'm good to go.
Now, let's do the same thing, but with a CSV file.
To do that, I'm just gonna get rid of this data
file, I'll just open up a new one. There we go.
I'll come back up to the file and open to data.
This time, I need to tell I'm looking for
a CSV, but if remember it that's actually
under text. So I click here. And except this
time, instead of selecting the dot txt file,
I'll select the dot CSV file. And what you find
is that the procedure is almost identical. There's
only one super tiny change here. I hit Continue.
I tell the variable names are at the top.
It is delimited. and nice to know that each line
is a case I just hit continue and all this. Here's
the one difference. When I did the text file tab
was automatically selected. Now that I'm doing a
CSV, which means comma separated values, comma is
automatically selected. I hit Continue. It does
the same thing with month we're going to leave
it as string I hit continue and I can hit Done.
And you see, it looks exactly the same. I do
have the same issue though, that these three
numbers which go from zero to 100, are coded as
nominal, I need to change them manually to scale.
Right. Now we'll do the third one, an
Excel file. Now in a lot of programs,
you get very stern warnings about importing
Excel files. And there's good reasons for that.
Because Excel files are very flexible, and people
can put a lot of stuff in there, again, comments
and changing column widths and merging cells that
make it easy to use Excel just for displaying
information. But if you're importing it don't want
to do that. Fortunately, I have it set up as tidy
data already. columns are the same as variables,
rows are the same as cases, there's nothing else
in there. And so what I can do in this case
is come to File, Open, we'll go to data again.
And this time I come down to this one,
it actually has Excel file as a format.
There it is, I'll hit open. And you'll see
that the dialog is different. In this case.
It says opening Excel data source instead
of the text import wizard. It says read the
variable names from the first row that's checked,
by default, it knows how many rows of data I have.
And it's got this thing about maximum width, I
don't need to worry about that I just hit OK.
And that was that. Here's the data from Excel,
it's the same data, I still need to
change these three measures manually,
you could save this information in syntax if
you're going to be doing it many times over.
But that is sufficient for the need. And so it
turns out that importing information into SPSS
is really easy. And it's massively more efficient
and easier to do than entering it directly.
You do it in a spreadsheet. And especially if you
do it on Google Sheets, if you're entering stuff
manually, you can collaborate on it. And then you
save it as a CSV file, and you pop it in there.
And then you can get straight to your analysis.
And that is the point of all this work anyhow.
And now in SPSS and introduction, we get to
the part that maybe you were waiting for,
and that's analyzing data. All mentioned. However,
I'm going to give only a very small overview of
analyzing data, because we have an entire
separate course here for data analysis, and
also data visualization in SPSS. And I recommend
that you check those out. But as a taste of what's
available, we'll talk about a procedure that's of
interest to a lot of people in applied settings.
And that's hierarchical clustering. Now, the
idea here is that you're trying to find clusters,
you're trying to find the clusters in your data.
More specifically, what you're trying to see is
whether similar cases cluster together in some way
that you can use to make inferences about them.
The trick, however, is that
similarity depends on your criteria.
And there's a few decisions that you have to make
when you're doing a cluster analysis of any kind.
So for instance, you have to decide whether you're
going to do a hierarchical cluster analysis,
which goes from one group to as many groups as
you have cases, or whether you're going to use
a set K or set number of clusters. You also have
to decide on the measures of distance that you're
going to use Euclidean distance, which is sort
of like measuring the as the crow flies distance
between cases is very common as his squared
Euclidean distance, which is what SPSS uses.
There's also the question of whether you want to
start with everything together and split it up
in a divisive procedure, or start with everything
separate and put it together in an agglomerative
procedure. By default, some programs
like our devices, but by default, SPSS
does agglomerative, you basically end up
with the same general findings anyhow,
so it's really not a huge difference.
So we're going to do a cluster analysis,
but we're going to try to keep it simple. We're
going to use some of the most basic methods for
doing this will use Euclidean distance or
squared Euclidean distance. In this case,
we'll use hierarchical clustering where we don't
have to choose the number of groups ahead of time.
And we're going to use an agglomerative procedure
where it starts with every case separate and then
gradually puts them together. Well try this
in SPSS, but I need you to do something first.
There is a folder that you can download from the
case files that ends with data here and in it
there's one file, it's cars dot save word SAE is
a proprietary SPSS data format. And in addition to
that, there is the SPSS syntax file and you'll
want both of those for this demonstration.
If you save the data file to your desktop,
it looks like this. You can just double click
on it and it will open up in SPSS, you also
have the option of using syntax to do that.
It depends on your operating system. This is for
a Macintosh right here. And this is for a Windows
computer though, you may need to use backslashes.
Instead, depending on your version of Windows.
I'm just gonna go back and double
click on this, to open it up in SPSS.
And there's my data set. What this data set
is, is a slight variation on a data set called
m t cars. That's in the default data sets package
in R. It contains road test data on a number of
cars from 1974, from the magazine Motor Trend. And
what we're going to do is we're going to look at
this information, we're going to see whether the
cars clustered together in some important way.
I'll go to the data view here. And you can see we
have Mazda RX four Hornet sport about Mercedes,
450, se, Lincoln, continental and so on cars
that were all available in the early 70s.
And we have information about miles per gallon.
We have the cylinders, we have the displacement
and cubic inches horsepower, weight in tons,
quarter second time in the standing quarter mile.
Whether it's an automatic or manual transmission,
the number of gears in the transmission.
And the number of carburetors are
probably carburetor barrels here,
I'm going to turn on the labels. Only one variable
changes here. By the way, one of the things I did
is I formatted this for SPSS by adding labels
and change some of the decimals makes it a
little easier to work with in the program.
But let's go to the syntax file right now.
Once we have the data open, we want to do a
default hierarchical clustering. Now this is
the code to produce it right here. But I'm
going to do it with the drop down menus to
show you that it's really not hard to do.
All we need to do is come up to analyze.
And then we come down to classify. Now
I have to admit off the top of my head,
I cannot remember if every version of SPSS
has this particular menu, most will, I hope
yours does. So you can follow along with this
hierarchical cluster. I'm going to click on that.
And what I'm going to do here is I'm going to take
Carnegie, which really tells me just says what the
cars are. And I'm going to use that to label cases
because that's going to mean something to me.
And I'm going to take all of my other variables
on the stool will shift click here and put them
over here. And at this moment, I'm going to change
nothing else, you'll see there's going to cluster
cases, that's what we want, it's going to give us
both some statistics and some plots, that's fine.
I'm going to hit OK. And we're going to get a
result identical to my first syntax command.
I see it sound I'll make the output window bigger
here. And here's what we have. First off, it tells
us how many cases there were and there were 32.
And they all had complete data, which is nice.
Then SPSS gives us something kind of unusual,
called an agglomeration schedule. And it really
specifies, at what point in the procedure did two
cases get put into the same cluster. I personally
don't have much use for this, except I know that
when there's a big jump in the coefficients as
there is here from three to 26, you know that
there's a very distinct category change as far
as from 662 1125, and so on. Most of the time,
though, I would just completely ignore this one.
And this, this is called an icicle plot. And
it's just sort of the same information about when
various cases got dropped in with everything else.
It's kind of pretty to look at, I find it kind of
meaningless. And so truthfully, the default
output for SPSS is hierarchical clustering
to me is not very helpful. In fact, it's so
unhelpful, I'm just going to delete it all.
And I'm going to do this over
again, come back up to my recent
menu items, I'm going to go to this analysis
again, I'm going to make a couple of changes.
I don't want the agglomeration schedule,
that doesn't really help me. And for plots,
I'm going to get rid of the icicle plot. And
then when you get a dendrogram instead of
dendogram. That means branches in Greek. So
it's a graph of the branches. And this is
usually the most important thing you can get out
of a hierarchical cluster analysis. I'll hit OK.
And now what we have is a chart here that
lists all the cases the cars on On the side,
and it shows how they grouped together. So
we see, for instance, these first four cars,
the Mazda RX four, and the wagon and the Mercedes
280 and two, etc, are very similar to one another,
they all go here together, we see
this a mother's, we come down here.
So for instance, the Cadillac Fleetwood, the
Lincoln Continental, the Chrysler Imperial, which
are all gargantuan American cars with big VAT,
they all go there together. And then we see down
here at the bottom, that this one, the mazarine
board is all by itself for a very long time.
This is where cases are individual here on the
left, and they gradually get put together. And
you see how they come together in each of these
branches. That's why it's called a dendrogram.
And so this is a really nice way of
seeing how similar your cases are.
And if you have more pixels displayed, you
can see the entire graph at once I've got a
low resolution right here. And you can see,
maybe it makes sense to split this off into, say,
four groups looks like we've got a distinct
group right here, right there, right there, and
right there. And so I can do something else with
this. I'm going to come back to the menu here.
And what I'm going to do is I'm
going to save group membership.
Now, I've done a hierarchical analysis. So I
didn't have to specify the number of groups. But
now that I've looked at the chart, for seems like
a good number. So I'm going to come here and say,
give me the group membership for each
case, breaking it down into four clusters.
I'll hit Continue. And then I'm going
to ask for it to not give me any plots.
I hit OK. And this time, we're not going to get
the output except for to say that it did the work.
Let's just get that. Here it says it it
processed them. The place where we're going
to see the differences in the data files,
I'm going to move over to the data file.
This button, by the way, will get me over to the
data. And now you can see I have a new variable
that got added here, for clusters for and you
can see that each of the cars is listed in one
of these four clusters. And what you can do then
is you can then take these cluster memberships,
and you can compare them on the
other variables. Again, remember,
the clustering here is only as valid as the data
that we give it. So it's only comparing these cars
on a small number of variables. And it's using
that to decide what goes with what it's here,
for instance, that you see them was Roddy Bora
is in a category all by itself. And this is a
neat way of looking at the similarity between
items. You can do it with people if you're doing
market research you can do with companies
if you're doing some sort of segmentation.
And it allows you to see what groups have
important similarities for what your purposes are,
and which groups you need to treat
differently as one another. That's the
goal of hierarchical clustering analysis. And
you find it's a very easy thing to do in SPSS.
Another important procedure in SPSS when you're
analyzing data is something called a factor
analysis. Now, I like to think of it as looking
at your data and trying to find shadows.
In this picture, what you have are shadows, those
are the black figures that you see, it takes a
moment to figure out that you're looking down and
there actually are people, but kind of sticking
straight out. And so in this photo, we are going
from a sort of a three dimensional origin, that's
the person itself to a two dimensional variation
with the shadow. What's interesting about that
is you maintain most of the useful data, you can
tell that there are people that they're walking,
you can probably even tell some things about how
tall they are, what they're wearing, and so on.
What you've done is you've made things more
efficient. Now in the data world, that's called
dimensionality reduction, where each variable is
a dimension. And too many variables can actually
be really problematic. You're trying to boil
things down a little bit. And you can think
about the saying less is more or less equals
more. More specifically, that is less noise,
and fewer unhelpful variables in your data set.
Equal more meaning because that's what you're
trying to do, you're trying to extract meaning.
Now, when it comes to factor analysis and related
techniques, I have one very important piece of
advice and that is to be practical. at all points,
you want to remember what is your goal? So what
is the goal? Well, the goal of factor analysis,
I'll tell you what it's not. It's not an exercise
in analytical purity. You're not there to show
that you know how to go through all the steps
in the approved format. Really, you're working
with your data Because you're trying to get
some understanding. So the goal of a procedure
like factor analysis is useful insight, trying
to follow the rules, do what you can to make
sure you don't make any obvious mistakes. But
remember, you're not bound by the mathematics,
you're bound by what the data tells you about
the people. Another way of looking at that is use
factor analysis, or really any other procedure
for us heuristic value. That is, it suggests
possibilities to you as you analyze the data
as you're trying to get insight to people. Now,
that's sort of a philosophical discouraging,
let me show you how this actually works in SPSS,
you're going to need to download from the course
files a folder that says data here at the end. And
from it the cars dot save dataset, this is the one
that we use in hierarchical clustering as well.
And then you want to open up the SPSS syntax
file that goes with this particular section.
Now, the easiest way to open the data set
is simply to double click on it and you'll
be ready to go. I do have some syntax you
can use if you saved it to your desktop.
I've got it open already. So let's
take a quick look at the data set.
We have a collection of cars listed down the
side and attributes like mpg and so on and
gears in the transmission and carburetors. That's
great. Now I will have to make a very important
confession here. This is a very, very
small data set for factor analysis.
It only has nine variables other than
the identifier, and it only has 32 cases,
really, you would want to have at least several
100 cases. And let's say several dozen variables
before you can do this really reliably. But this
example works. And it, it actually is really easy
to see how it's happening, and how to interpret
the results. The first thing we're going to do,
if you look at the syntax, is we're going
to do a default factor analysis. And it's
actually a misnomer, because it's not a factor
analysis. It's principal components analysis,
but it's in the factor analysis command
within SPSS. So let's come up here to analyze.
And down to dimension reduction. Remember I
said that's what this is called pick factor,
It's our only choice there. And what we need to
do is choose the variables that we're going to use
to see what we can compress what goes into what so
we don't need the name of the car, that's just an
identifier. We can take the rest of these however,
and we can put them under variables. Now we've got
a lot of options here, I'm not going to do any
of them, I'm just going to hit OK for right now.
And make the output window bigger. And here's
what we get from the default analysis, we get a
text output of the commands that were
generated by the drop down menus,
we get something called communality. each
variable brings with it one unit of standardized
variance. That's based on how spread out
the scores are. And if you standardize them,
then you have a variance and the standard
deviation of one for each. And the extraction
tells us how much of that variance is really able
to get constituted through the process that we're
doing. An important one right here is the total
variance explained because what this has done is
it has created components memory said this is
actually a principal components analysis here,
which well, it has profoundly different
philosophical underpinnings from factor analysis,
the difference has to do with which came first,
the factors or the observed variables. And
truthfully, most people treat them
as relatively interchangeable. And if
you're using them for heuristic value,
it's not going to be a big difference.
But what we have here are two components, we
have one with 5.472 units of variance that 61%
of the original variance of the nine variables,
and then another one with 2.341. I'm getting
those numbers from right here. And you can see
it held on to these two, which collectively
add up to about 87% of the variance. Now the
component matrix shows the relationship between
the original variables and the two components.
These are like correlation coefficients,
you can see that mpg is strongly negatively
associated with the first component and really
not associated with the second. But number of
carburetors has a pretty strong association with
each. And so that's a way to start to look at
it. But it's going to be a lot easier if we do
certain modifications to this. In fact, I'm
going to just delete this output right here.
And we're going to start over
I'm going to make a few changes
Let's go through each of these options. First
we go to the descriptives. And I don't really
feel like I need the initial solution. So
I'm going to unselect that I'll hit Continue.
extraction. This is the actual algorithm that
SPSS uses to work through the relationships
in the multi dimensional space. You'll see
right here is principal components. That's
why I said this is really a principal components
analysis, you've got a lot of options here. Now,
in many situations, maximum likelihood would
be a very good answer, I'm going to choose
principal axis factoring simply because it's
the classical version of factor analysis.
I don't need to see the unrotated factor solution,
but I do want to see something called a scree
plot. And that is a graph that shows me
maybe how many factors I should keep,
I'm going to come down here and change the maximum
iterations for convergence that has to do with the
math, that's done, I'm going to change it to 50.
Then I'm going to come to rotation, what you
get here is a multi dimensional space. And
sometimes it's a little easier. If you rotate,
the axes can increase interpretability. Now,
there are a lot of different methods. varimax is
a method that maintains orthogonal relationships
that makes all of your axes perpendicular to each
other. There are situations where that's really
good. But truthfully, for exploratory purposes,
which is what we're doing, I like to use what's
called an oblique rotation, that allows your
factors to be correlated with each other,
they don't have to be totally perpendicular.
I'm gonna use direct oblem. And promax is
another really good choice. But it usually is for
larger data sets, and I've got a tiny one here.
Now, here, I can get a rotated solution,
I don't think I really need that. But I do
want to see the loading plot. And I'm going to
increase the maximum number of iterations to 50.
I'll hit Continue. We'll come down
to scores. And you can save the
factor loadings as scores. And there might
be situations where you want to do that.
But because I'm using factor analysis for its
heuristic value, as a way, suggesting what
variables to go with others, I'm actually not
going to do that. So I'm going to hit cancel.
Then finally, options. This is where you get to
talk about excluding cases, I have a complete data
set, so I don't need to worry about that.
But the coefficient display format, now,
I'm going to sort it and then I'm
actually going to have it completely
erase small coefficients. Now I've done this
one before. So I happen to know that a value
of point six, under normal circumstances has
really high. But given my very small data set,
this seems like a reasonable choice.
And it makes the solution very,
very clear when we look at it. So I'm going to
hit Continue. And then there, I'm going to hit OK.
I've got my output here. And the first part is
pretty similar, except it doesn't start with a
unit variance for each of these. That's because
I'm not doing principal components anymore. I'm
doing principal axis factoring. And so the math
behind it's a little bit different. But we don't
need to dwell on that one. total variance
explained, you see that we still have two
factors. And the first one accounts for a lot
of the variance, the second one accounts for
a fair amount also, and these are very close
to what we had with the principal components.
The scree plot, is a very simple line pot. This
suggests how many factors we might want to keep.
Now there are several different rules you can
use for interpreting this. One is anything that's
above a value of one because one is what it would
be if a variable explained simply one unit of
variance, but that's what it brought with it, you
want factors that have been explained more than
that. And you see we have two that do a lot more
than one and these others are sort of straggling
down. The other rule is to look for a bend in
the line and you do see a strong band right here.
So three is where the band is, we're justified in
saying with two, there are other methods to get
more involved about checking for the slope of this
line and finding things that are above that slope.
You can do those in another time. This is
a quick demonstration. Now what we get next
are three matrices, we get a factor matrix, a
pattern matrix, and a structure matrix. They're
all associated with each other. And I've got a
little note here in the syntax that explains them.
I'll come down here. The factor matrix is the
Association of each variable with each factor and
it's similar in nature, it's analogous to our the
correlation coefficient. That's the one that we're
going to be focusing on. The structure matrix
tells us how much each variable is predicted by
the factors because the idea Here's the factors
come first and variables come second, using what
are called the unique and common contribution.
So a factor might contribute something on its own
compared to the other factors or it contributes
together. And then the pattern matrix is an
indication of each factor is unique contribution
to variables variance. Those can both be important
in different situations, and they can help you
interpret things. But for right now, I'm just
going to focus on this first one. There we go, the
factor matrix. So let me go back to where I was.
And when we come up to the factor matrix,
what you see here is because I suppressive
values with an absolute value of less than point
six, we have this totally clear separation.
Factor one is strongly associated with the number
of cylinders in the car. So more cylinders higher
on factor one, and then displacement, very high,
mpg is negative, but very strong. And then we have
weight in tons very strong in horsepower. This is
really the big factor cars that are really big are
going to score heavily on factor one. factor two
is composed of the number of gears and more gears,
the quarter mile time, so the less time it
takes to get through the quarter mount that is,
the faster it is. That's because
it's negative here, the higher it is
automatic or manual, you have to know
that zero is automatic, and one is
manual. So these are manual transmission
cars, and those with more carburetors.
This is really the fast factor. And that's
where sports cars are going to this one,
this one has the Cadillacs and the Lincoln's and
this one has the Ferraris and the Lotus isn't and
so on. And that makes perfect sense, it's really
easy to see why that would be the way it is.
And then if you come down here, this plot is
also really helpful, it's got the two factors,
we have factor one across the bottom, that's
our big factor. And you can see that weight
goes on that one displacement goes on that
one cylinder, and then we have number of
years and miles per gallon, obviously, you're
on the low end. factor two is the fast factor.
More carburetors, more horsepower, more
cylinders, and lower quarter mile times.
And that makes a lot of sense. And so this
lets us know that we could boil down our data
to really just these two factors, sort of how
big is the car, and how fast is it. And that
can give us a much more concise image of our
data, and allows us to extract more meaning and
that is the overall purpose of a procedure like
factor analysis or principal components in SPSS.
For a final look at SPSS and analyzing data,
at least in this brief overview course,
let's take a look at one of the most useful
procedures around regression. Now, you might think
of regression as sort of the statistical version
of The Three Musketeers where it's all for one.
I say that because all for one is actually
all variables for predicting one outcome.
Put another way, regression uses many different
variables many predictor variables to predict
scores on one outcome variable. This makes it
really useful in a huge range of circumstances,
especially because there's something for everyone
with regression. There are many different versions
of it and many adaptations of regression that make
it truly flexible, and powerful. When analyzing
data and make it a go to tool for almost any
analytical purpose you might have. We'll try
a simple version of this in SPSS. First, make sure
you've downloaded this data folder from the course
files. It will use the cars dot save data set
that we've used in our two previous examples,
along with this syntax file. And when you
get to this index file, it begins as usual.
With the code for loading the data set from the
desktop truthfully, is easier to just double click
on the file cars dot save and haven't opened it
up directly in SPSS. That's what I've done here.
And you can see is the same data set with about
32 rows of data, a bunch of cars from 1974.
And several variables we're going
to try to predict in this one is
miles per gallon, based on things like the
number of cylinders the displacement, horsepower,
weighed quarter, second time transmission
and kind and gears and carburetors.
Alright, so that should be pretty easy. What
we're going to do is go to analyze, and come down
to regression. And we'll use this second option
here linear. That's just basic linear regression.
Now we need to put under dependent the outcome
variable, the thing we're trying to predict,
kind of bugs me here, because independent
and dependent really should be reserved for
manipulated experiments. But
we still know what they mean,
our outcome variable, the thing that we're
trying to predict goes here independent.
So that's mpg. Now we can take everything
else except car name, that's just a
label, we'll take all the rest of these and we'll
put them under our independent or the variables
that we are using to predict the outcome. Now,
I want to do the totally default, no extra steps
version first. So I've put the variables in
their respective place. And I'll just hit OK.
And now we get our output. And it tells us first,
the code that was used to produce this analysis,
that it used all of these variables
simultaneously to predict a single outcome,
which is listed down here. And they were entered
at once. The model summary tells us that we have a
multiple correlation of these predictor variables
with our outcome variable of point 931, which is
really high. If you square that to get the
proportion of variance explained it's 86.7%.
Even the adjusted R squared, because we have
a small sample is still 82%. It's It's huge.
We get a significance test right here, we are
not surprised to see that the significant is
point 000. It's not zero all the way through,
but it's it's highly significant. And then we
get coefficients for the individual regression
coefficients. So what we're looking for here are
significance levels that are under oh five, and
interestingly, only one of them in this collection
is under oh five and that weight in tunt. None of
the others are there close. That doesn't mean that
none of the others matter. It simply means that
when you take all of the variables together at the
same time, when they are taken as a whole, really
only one of them deviates significantly from zero
to become a predictor. That's a wait. Now, there
are a lot of other ways of doing regression.
And SPSS gives you a lot of choices. I'm going to
come up here, back to analyze, down to regression.
Now I will mention, there's a really interesting
one here called automatic linear modeling. This is
a SPSS function, it's came in a few versions ago,
it does a lot of automatic Data Prep, it does a
lot of combining and splitting up the variables.
On the other hand, it's really kind of difficult
to explain how it all works. And then to interpret
it properly. I'm going to save that for another
course where I specifically talk about analyzing
data. For now I'm going to go back to linear.
And we're going to make a few choices,
we're going to make a few options, rephrase.
And we're going to make a few choices, we're
going to take some of the options that SPSS
makes available. Now the first one I'm going to do
at the risk of doing something very controversial,
is I'm actually going to go from simultaneous
entry to stepwise regression. This is
controversial because some people in the
literature have called it positively diabolic.
And its risk of a type one or false positive
error. And there's some good evidence for that.
On the other hand, in modern machine learning,
stepwise procedures have been very fruitful
use. And so it's not totally unacceptable to
try, especially when we're doing sort of an
exploratory project like this right now,
you certainly wouldn't want to use it for
rigorous model building, but it's a nice way to
get some insight into the data pretty quickly.
I'll come just to statistics, and I'm going to
add a few things, I'm going to get confidence
intervals for the coefficients, those are nice to
have, we have the overall model fit. And I'm going
to get the R squared change, because a stepwise
model goes through several different steps, adding
variables. And we want to see if each variable
adds something that is statistically significant
to the overall model. We could get a lot more
information here, but I'll leave it there for now.
Under plots, we can get a ton of different
plots, but I'm actually just going to come
down here and choose the standardized residual
plots a histogram and a normal probability plot.
Now there are other options as well. I could save
about 15 different kinds of scores to the data
set. I can say unstandardized predicted values, I
can save studentized, deleted residuals, and so on
and so forth. things I could do here and there are
situations in which I might want to do those. But
for right now, I'm going to skip them because I'm
simply trying to build a model without necessarily
saving all of the steps in between Options really
just talks about the criteria used in the stepwise
procedure, I'm gonna leave it at the default right
now, but you could change it if you wanted to.
And then style is a new thing that has
to do with the formatting of the table.
I'm going to leave that one alone for right now,
because we're going to have exactly what we need.
Now I've created this already, and I've
saved it in the syntax, I'm just going to hit
OK. And you'll see that we get a different
kind of output right now. I'll zoom in on this.
Now what we have is some code that's a little bit
longer, this has to go through the variables one
at a time. And find the predictive variable that
is most strongly associated with the outcome,
put it in the model, get partial correlations
and go through step after step. What we find
here is that although we had nine predictors,
originally, only two of them were statistically
significant when put into the model. They
were weight, and number of cylinders.
Again, what we're trying to predict is gas mileage
mpg. If you come down here, you can see that they
were both statistically significant, or the
adjusted R squared for just weight is 74.5.
And when you add on number of cylinders, it goes
up. Not a huge amount, but it goes up almost 8%.
The analysis of variance table lets us
know that both of these models with just
one variable and with two predictor variables,
they're both statistically significant.
Here are the individual coefficients along
with their confidence intervals over here on
the right side. Now, because we've gone through a
stepwise procedure, it's not surprising that all
of these are statistically significant, because
that was the criterion used for including them.
Here we have a list of excluded variables along
with their colinearity statistics. And this has
to do with how much each of these variables is
correlated with the others. So for instance,
number of carburetors is highly colinear,
or easily predicted by the other variables
that we could have included in the model.
Now we come down to the residuals, I'm
going to look specifically at the chart.
In an ideal world, your residuals are normally
distributed, which means they're just as likely to
be high as they are low, and they're symmetrical.
And we see here that they're not horribly,
pathologically far from normal. So this is
probably a good model on the set. And here's
a normal p p probability probability plot of
this same data. And if it were perfectly normal,
all the dots would be on the line, the diagonal
line, they're close. These are the 32 individual
observations and how far off they're, they're
close enough. And so this lets us know that our
model is predicting really well and it appears
to be not biased in one direction or another.
So this is one method of developing a model.
Again, this stepwise procedure is best for
exploratory analyses, it's not something
you would use for confirming a finding.
But as a quick way of sifting through a
large collection of potential variables,
this is a nice way to do it. It lets us know for
instance, that in this particular data set mpg
is predicted primarily by a weight, which
completely makes sense about the car,
and number of cylinders, which is associated with
having a large and thirsty engine. So the general
idea of multiple regression, again, is to use
many variables to predict a single outcome, SPSS
gives a lot of options for those we've looked at
the default we looked at one variation on there,
but there's a lot more that you can explore
and that we will cover in another course on
statistical analysis in SPSS. But for now,
I encourage you to take some time and look
at some of these options and see the kind of
insight that they can give you on your own data,
and see what options you can use to get
useful insight into your own analyses.
I want to thank you for joining
me in SPSS and introduction.
And we'll conclude by giving you some next steps,
things that you can do next, because you know,
once you get through this, it can be a little
confusing, feel like things are going everywhere.
And it may not be totally clear where you should
go. Well, here at data lab.cc, we've got a few
opportunities for you. First, of course, is
more SPSS, we have additional courses on data
preparation, on data visualization, on statistical
analysis, and other topics that you can use
to expand what you've learned in this introductory
course, and work on your own data. Now, if you've
liked what you've learned with SPSS, you may want
to try branching out into some other languages.
This statistical programming language R and the
general purpose programming language Python,
are very common powerful tools in the data
science community and analytics in general.
They're a great way to To expand both the
things that you can do with your analyses and
your employment opportunities, and so, I strongly
encourage you to take a look at the courses on our
in Python data lab. Next, we have specific courses
on data visualization, one of the most important
things you can do in getting to understand your
data. SPSS can work well in those as well as
other programs. And then I'm going to mention one
final thing here. SPSS is a wonderful program,
but it still has a fair amount of bugs and
it can also be very expensive. Fortunately,
some really interesting work recently in the
open source community has developed a program
called j SB. It's actually pronounced Jasper,
which is sort of an open source version of SPSS,
it runs very differently, I find it very easy to
use, and it makes it reproducible. It makes it
easy to share. It's got some tremendous advantages
and we have courses on Jasper here today lab,
I suggest you check those out and see how well
that program is able to fulfill some of your
computing needs. That being said, there are some
things missing. What's missing exactly? Well, SPSS
doesn't have a really strong and active user and
developer community the same way that languages
like R and Python do. But if you're creative,
you can get around that academic conferences,
meaning specifically topical academic conferences
like biology or management or the social sciences.
They often have very dedicated SPSS users,
and teachers and may sponsor specific hands
on workshops for learning more about SPSS and
how I can use it within your particular domain.
But no matter what you do, I'm going to encourage
you to simply get started, go exploring and see
what you can do with SPSS in your own data work.
Thanks so much for joining me and happy computing